fais toi plaisir
la super atterrissage de super-héros
regarde regarde
super atterrissage samedi que les genoux
faut le savoir
ça sert à rien mais tout le monde le
fait et tout à fait charmante mais je me
garde pour francis tu vois les compotes
je préfère pas à frapper une femme alors
s'il vous plaît
je veux dire tu vois avec ma pote
non non finito truite au contraire c'est
tu nous donnes de seconde ouais vas-y
acheta a les pattes à faire
quand je plains le petit plus haut qui
va lui mettre la pression pour coucher
si oui pourquoi c'est si cool entre nous
pourquoi là
et voilà on a le même fait au casque
mais grave
on est comme deux pièces d'un puzzle
tu vois les les bords incurvés visa et
quand on est ensemble on reconstitue à
beauté voilà je voulais te demander
quelque chose parce que je me dis que
toi tu ne seras pas tu vois pas la
mesure
on est cinq ans oui vous savez cacher ça